moi
voilà
cobee39 transfert
je
le papa
histoire de l'aviation la conquête de
l'espace destination lune s'est dit si
sur ce cap de floride cap canaveral
il y a un peu plus de 25 ans qu'est
partie la plus grande aventure jamais
entreprise par l'homme
c'est par une journée comme celle ci que
l'un des plus vieux rêves de l'humanité
devait se réaliser
trois hommes se préparaient à aller sur
la lune et à revenir sur terre c'était
un tournant pour l'histoire de l'homme
en cas de réussite de la mission
l'espèce humaine était plus condamnés à
vivre indéfiniment sur la tête
c'était le premier pas vers les étoiles
c'était l'événement le plus important de
l'histoire
c'était véritablement historique la
première fois qu'un sommes allés sur la
lune nous apparaissait impossible
c'était l'aboutissement de toutes les
connaissances que l'homme avait accumulé
jusque là nous sommes le 16 juillet 1969
il est 4h30 du matin les trois
astronautes neil armstrong buzz aldrin
et michael collins vérifie l'étanchéité
de leurs combinaisons
à l'extérieur les projecteurs de la
télévision scrute les ténèbres sur la
plage de cocobeach chez ceux qui sont
venus célébrer l'événement l'ambiance de
fête fait place à une tension angoisses
et des milliers de gens se sont
rassemblés le long de la route
3000 journalistes sont là et un millier
sont présents au centre de contrôle de
houston
on compte plus d'un million de personnes
en tout à la veille de la plus grande
aventure humaine
le monde entier retient son souffle il
n'y a jamais eu de moment plus
enthousiasmant dans l'histoire que la
période qui a précédé le lancement un
coq au pic au moment précis où nous
étions prêts à lancer un homme dans
l'espace et par tout le monde se sont
impliqués dans la mission du plus petit
balayeur jusqu'au techniciens les plus
importants fonds brand les astronautes
tout le monde était tendue vers un seul
but explorer l'espace le conquérir débat
c'est l'atmosphère
c'était impressionnant de voir à quel
point tout le monde se sont éteints
forcément concernés
c'est le départ un véhicule amène les
trois astronautes vers la rampe 39 à
trois hommes grâce à qui le monde ne
sera jamais plus tout à fait le même
le risque semble est si énorme
c'était une entreprise tellement
courageuse qu'on avait peine à croire
que ça allait se réaliser
c'était tellement risqué qu'on pouvait
penser qu'aucune personne en possession
de toute cette note andré une telle
mission
nous avons sélectionné un petit groupe
d'astronautes qui se sentait capable
d'effectuer n'importe quelle opération
dans l'espace on peut résumer l'état
d'esprit qui régnait chez eux de la
manière suivante
donnez-nous juste des moufles et un
short et tout se passera bien
pendant toute la période qui a précédé
le moment du départ nous étions inquiets
qu'il se passe quelque chose qui
interrompent la mission l'ascenseur
s'élève
à 6h52 armstrong collins et aldrin
pénètre dans la fusée on scelle les
accès les astronautes sont seuls au
centre de contrôle de houston
l'équipe de contrôle verrouille la porte
de la salle l'ambiance est un mélange
d'optimisme outrancier et d'anxiété
insoutenable
je suis entré dans la salle de contrôle
ce jour-là j'ai senti l'atmosphère d'une
journée d'exception
notre mission est rude il n'était pas
seulement question d'essayer mais de
réussir
il s'agissait de faire atterrir un homme
sur la lune
ce fut un moment émouvant lorsque
j'annonce l équipe des contrôleurs et
bien voilà aujourd'hui nous allons
réaliser un vol dans la lune heures hb -
60 secondes
la fusée géante saturn 5 gronde et
exhale des vapeurs tel un dragon un
patient au centre de contrôle les
chercheurs et les ingénieurs sont
inquiets devant l'inconnu
nous étions beaucoup entraînés à réagir
en cas d'anomalie de circonstances
imprévues et on s'inquiète toujours de
ce qu'on n'a pas prévu de ce pour quoi
on n'est pas préparé la plupart d'entre
nous croyez que ce que symbolise le dieu
apollon
c'est à dire que si l'on s'entraîne
régulièrement ont fini par réussir à la
nasa tout le monde était entraîné les
astronautes les contrôleurs de vol tout
le monde
tout le monde était prêt prêt à réaliser
cette chose qui semblait complètement
folle
heures hb - 40 secondes
le directeur des équipes de vol dicks
layton s'inquiète de l'état physique et
mentale des astronautes
ils sont fatigués la pression et les
longues heures d'entraînement commence à
peser
mais les astronautes font savoir qu'il
se sent en pleine forme
pourquoi
mais là
non
il est 9h30 deux sur la côte est des
états unis nous sommes le 16 juillet
les cinq moteurs f1 de la fusée saturn
is l'engin dans le ciel au cours des
neuf premières secondes de vol ils vont
consommer plus de 38 tonnes de carburant
l'ong sonore fait vibrer la terre comme
si une éruption volcanique allait se
produire
sanglés dans leurs capsules armstrong
collins et aldrin s'élève dans le ciel
le voyant de l'allumage des moteurs
s'est allumée et l'ong sonore a déferlé
sur le désert avec une force gigantesque
jusqu'à nous on pourrait presque la
palper fut un moment d'émotion intense
il y avait des hommes à bord de cet
engin
ces hommes partaient pour une mission
extrêmement périlleuse et les probable
qu'aucune aventure humaine n'était est
lancée avec autant de tumulte que le
lancement de la fusée saturn 5 portant
le vaisseau spatial apollo
le vrombissement est venu jusqu'à nous
comme pour annoncer l'importance de ce
vol à tous ceux qui étaient présents
c'est de nous c'est l humanité toute
entière qui partait vers la lune cela
semblait difficile à croire
une fusée emportant des hommes à son
bord s'envolait pour la lune
c'était la science qui avait rendu
possible cette aventure mais toute cette
technologie avait trouvé son impulsion
première dans l'esprit de certains
visionnaires de l'espace c'est en russie
sous le règne du tsar nicolas deux cas
un instituteur russe konstantin
tsiolkovski s'intéressa au voyage dans
la lune
il inventa la théorie du mouvement
réactif il imagina une fusée propulsée
par un mélange d'hydrogène et d'oxygène
liquide
rien à voir avec les 200 tonnes de
poudre auquel jules verne avait pensé
vingt ans après de l'autre côté du monde
un autre visionner réfléchit lui aussi
un voyage dans la lune c'était le savant
américain robert goddard
en 1926 il réalisa ce que ciolkowski
avait imaginé en lançant la première
fusée en carburant liquide
le vol ne durera que deux secondes et
demi et atténue une hauteur de 12 m
mais la technologie qui devait permettre
à l'homme de marcher sur la lune était
née herrmann hobert fut le troisième
grand pionniers de la conquête de
l'espace
il connaissait bien les oeuvres de jules
verne et de wells
il écrivit un livre sur les voyages
interplanétaires qui popularisa l'idée
du voyage dans l'espace et des fusées
parmi ceux qui travaillaient avec hobert
il y avait un jeune étudiant de 18 ans
wernher von braun qui devint plus tard
le spécialiste des fusées en allemagne
et devaient par la suite mené l'homme
dans la lune fonds monétaire m2 et d'un
ensemble de caractéristiques
exceptionnelles
c'était un visionnaire on peut le
constater déjà dans le journal qu'il
tenait enfants dans ses dessins dans les
rêves qu'il faisait et tous les
témoignages de ses camarades d'enfance
le coup c'était aussi un ingénieur
excellent il a conçu des choses
extraordinaires comme cet immense
station spatiale avec 70 personnes à
bord pour atteindre mars c'est une
conception grandiose en tant
qu'ingénieur il était très conventionnel
il savait travailler avec d'autres
personnes ils avaient les qualités d'un
véritable politiciens un sens des
relations publiques hors pair il a dit
un jour pour obtenir le soutien
nécessaire un véritable programme
spatial il faut faire appel au public et
la conquête de l'espace
est ce que von braun avait près
pendant ce temps dans les plaines
venteuses du kazakhstan le grand savant
russe serge pavlov korolev concevaient
la fusée qui allait permettre à l'homme
d'effectuer son premier vol dans
l'espace
le 4 octobre 1957 les soviétiques
lancèrent le spoutnik qui devait être le
premier satellite artificiel de la terre
il ne s'agissait que d'une petite boule
de fil et de métal dont le poids
n'excède pas 80 kg mais ce succès était
le premier pas vers le voyage dans la
lune et la conquête de l'espace
après le décollage le moment critique et
elle est traversée de l'atmosphère puis
la séparation des propulseurs d'appoint
tout ça s'est passé de manière très
rapprochée
tous ces moments de tension se sont
enchaînées avec l'attention du départ
ensuite il y eut la longue croisière
jusqu'à la lune la cabine drones et
lentement sur elle-même à raison d'1
tours par minute et on pouvait xsr passé
la lune tout doucement par le hublot
puis après la lune on voyait passer la
terre c'était fantastique quand ils se
sont approchés la lune il a fallu que
l'on je fasse quelques petites
corrections intermédiaire pour se mettre
sur la bonne trajectoire
ensuite le moment critique a été l'ami
sur orbite autour de la lune
tous ceux qui connaissent l enchaînement
des opérations avaient les yeux braqués
sur leurs écrans vidéo pour voir ce qui
se passait à houston et dans la cabine à
ce moment là il ya eu une véritable
explosion de joie quand on a vu qu'ils
avaient réussi à se mettre sur orbite
il y a maintenant 80 3h02 qu'apollo est
en vol les astronautes vont maintenant
utiliser le module lunaire eagle l'aigle
c'était la première fois que le nom
convenu retentissait il retentit aussi à
400 mille kilomètres de là sur la terre
quand le soleil était au zénith
il était midi sur la lune elle avait
l'air d'un endroit d'où et accueillant
mais quand il se levait où on se
couchait elle prenait une toute autre
apparence l'ombre des cratères
s'allonger et ça devenait un endroit
vraiment inhospitalier il semblait à
peine croyable que seulement 12 ans se
soient écoulés depuis le vol de spoutnik
l'annnonce de la mise en orbite du
spoutnik a provoqué une sorte de réveil
de la technologie en amérique
nous nous étions toujours considéré
comme supérieur dans le domaine de la
recherche scientifique
pour les américains il était difficile
d'accepter l'idée que les soviétiques
avec tout ce que le régime bolchévique
représenter pour inférieur en termes de
modes de vie et le degré développement
soit en avance sur nous lorsque le
succès du spoutnik et a connu les
américains furent complètement atterrée
de n'être que les secondes puis les
soviétiques ont lancé des engins avec
des chiens bord le 5 octobre 1958
exactement un an et trois jours après le
lancement du spoutnik naquit le
programme mercury l'amérique entre est
ainsi officiellement dans un projet de
lancement d'un homme dans l'espace avec
le programme mercury
il s'agissait de passer du vol en avion
au vol dans l'espace c'était quelque
chose de complètement nouveau nous
explorions un domaine entièrement
inconnu nous ne savions pas exactement
ce que nous faisions mais nous le
faisons tous les jours nous étions trop
jeunes pour avoir peur de quoi que ce
soit
nous aimions le défi mais ce fut bien
plus difficile que nous ne l'avions
imaginé nous progressions de manière
totalement inexpérimentés dans nos
recherches nous avons eu beaucoup de
chance c'est la confiance qui nous à
faire en avril 1959 un peu plus d'un an
après le lancement du premier satellite
américain explorer 1
cet homme allait devenir les nouveaux
héros du 20e siècle
alan shepard john glenn gould grissom
scott carpenter ou ali chira gordon
cooper et dicks layton furent désignés
pour former la première équipe
d'astronautes américains
toutefois nous sommes devenus célèbres
j'ai des lieutenants je pilotais un f4
comme pas mal de gars et du jour au
lendemain je suis devenu quelqu'un
d'unique sont prêts si nous sommes allés
tous les sept à la base d'edwards où
nous avons rencontré scott grosse field
que j'ai toujours admiré il nous a
regardés de haut et nous est dit
pourquoi êtes-vous si connue vous n'avez
encore rien fait et c'était vrai mais
c'est comme ça que nous avons été reçus
ça nous a rapprochés
nous sommes devenus des frères nous
étions devenus des héros des gens dont
le nom restera dans les livres
d'histoire mais vous savez quand on est
assis sur 2700 tonnes de carburant
hautement explosif
c'est vraiment la dernière chose à
laquelle on pense à cap canaveral au
printemps 1961
les astronautes américains du projet
mercury font des paris sur celui d'entre
eux qui sera le premier dans l'espace
tout est prêt c'est une alliance
extraordinaire de technique et de
puissance pure la fusée a
sur la rampe numéro 5 pendant ce temps
en russie youri gagarine se prépare à
ébahir le monde
le 12 avril 1961 à 9h07 heure de moscou
il est envoyé dans l'espace à son retour
il déclarera j'ai bien regardé mais je
n'ai pas vu dieu wernher von braun
dépité fit remarquer que lorsque nous
arriverions sur la lune
il nous faudrait passer par la douane
soviétique le vol de youri gagarine le
premier vol habité dans l'espace captiva
l'attention des gens dans le monde
entier mais il donna aussi un coup de
fouet au programme américain
les soviétiques venait de battre les
américains dans l'espace pour la
deuxième fois la première fois avec le
satellite la deuxième avec le premier
vol habité
nous étions en train d'étudier la
possibilité d'un vol sur orbite
et voilà que les soviétiques on voit
gagarine autour de la terre puis titre
et ça nous a donné un sacré coup au
moral mais nous nous sommes accrochés au
lieu d'abandonner
nous sommes remis au travail et nous
avons tenu bon la principale difficulté
était de mettre au point un lanceur
assez puissant pour apporter un grand
j'ai habité moins d'un mois après le vol
de gagarine
les américains se préparait à
s'aventurer dans le monde inconnu de
l'espace la foule et la presse étaient
déjà fasciné par cette course vers
l'espace
la presse s'intéresse à nous mais en
fait nous sommes devenus des héros
simplement parce que nous avons été
volontaires pour remplacer des
chimpanzés c'est tout je ne me considère
pas comme un héros pour ça nous en
présentons entre nous cette époque là je
raconte souvent que nous recevions des
télégrammes de la spa nous demandant
d'arrêter les vols expérimentaux avec
les singes alors on a fait beau les
annales shepard
il n'aime pas trop le raconter
le 5 mai 1961
alan shepard s'envola de cap canaveral
dans l'espace sur la fusée conçu par von
braun
elle s'appelait freedom 7 l'amérique
venait enfin d'envoyer un homme dans
l'espace
une chose très intéressante est arrivé
après mon vol chaufferie oms est allé à
washington pour être décoré par le
président kennedy et des filets avec
johnson qui était vice-président et nous
devions repartir l'après-midi man au
dernier moment
kennedy nous a dit quand le défilé sera
terminée revenez me voir pour une
réunion
ce n'était pas prévu nous sommes
retournés dans le bureau ovale et là il
nous a dit maintenant racontez nous
comment ça s'est passé
et qu'est ce que vous avez ressenti tout
l'intéressé le 27 mai 1961 21 jours
seulement après le premier vol d' alan
shepard le président kennedy prittas
risques énormes en face du congrès des
états unis il promis devant le monde
entier que l'amérique envers est un
homme sur la lune avant la fin de la
décennie
il mise en jeu et sa réputation et sa
carrière politique sur la réalisation du
plus vieux rêve de l'homme les
historiens ont dit que c'était un acte
politique
je pense que tous ceux qui ce faire la
maison blanche est considéré comme un
acte politique mais je suis convaincu
que c'était une décision personnelle
pour moi ce n'était pas un acte
politique j'ai reçu un coup de téléphone
en virginie m'annonçant la visite du
président à houston au texas
on me demandait d'aller au texas en tant
que directeur d'une partie du projet et
d'expliquer au président comment nous
allions nous y prendre pour envoyer un
homme sur la lune
j'ai répondu vous plaisantez je ne sais
pas comment nous allons dû s'y prendre
je peux vous dire que je me suis
débrouillé pour trouver quelque chose ça
m'a pris deux semaines et je suis a
expliqué au président comment nous
allons envoyer un homme sur la lune
kennedy avait été élevée dans une
famille
mais les défis les soviétiques avaient
défié notre pays en envoyant un homme
dans l'espace avant nous il avait bien
l'intention de relever ce défi il tenait
vraiment à prouver au monde que
l'amérique était le pays le plus avancé
technologiquement moins de neuf mois
plus tard le 20 février 1962
des dizaines de millions de
téléspectateurs dans le monde
pu revoir la fusée mercury emportant
john glenn monter dans le ciel pour
effectuer trois révolutions autour de la
terre
le vol allait durer quatre heures et 55
minutes
glenn était le premier astronaute
américain à voir le soleil se lever et
se coucher à une distance de 320 km de
la terre il restait beaucoup de choses
avant c'était le but de ses premiers
vols halford effectué le premier vol
puis goss grissom c'était des vols
suborbitaux des allers retours de 15 à
20 minutes
on vole fut le premier vol orbital nous
avions acquis une certaine expérience du
vol en apesanteur pour pouvoir réagir au
cas où il y aurait eu un problème à son
retour sur terre
john glenn devint un héros national et
l'objectif initial du projet mercury
placer un homme sur orbite avait été
atteint
après trois autres vols mercury réussi
il était temps de passer au programme
gemini et de faire un autre pas vers la
lune nous avions commencé avec mercury
et le président kennedy elle y allant
sur la lune certains ont pensé que nous
pourrions le faire tout de suite après
mais nous n'étions pas prêts il fallait
et perfectionner tout le processus
je crois que les progrès à partir de
mercury se sont fait très vite le
programme gemini était un programme
intermédiaire il nous a permis
d'apprendre un certain nombre de choses
qui étaient nécessaires pour ensuite
aller dans la lune gemini et est donc
une étape vers apollo
ce n'était pas un programme en choix
le programme gemini n'était qu'une étape
mais chacun de ces dix vols fascinèrent
l'imagination du public
des milliers de spectateurs regard des
red white sortir dans l'espace lors du
vol gemini 4
reliés par un cordon à la capsule white
reste à 22 minutes dans l'espace
six mois plus tard en décembre 65 /
gemini 7 franck baumann et james lowell
établir le record de durée en vol dans
l'espace avec 14 jours et réaliser
l'objectif initial du programme gemini
l'arrimage sur orbite avec gemini 6
piloté par où aller chira et tom
stafford
lors de ce vol sur gemini avec stafford
nous avons rejoint gemini set c'était
notre destination des mini 7 tenter de
prouver que la capsule pouvait rester
deux semaines dans l'espace le temps
qu'il fallait pour aller dans la lune et
revenir on joue aux trois jours bruit et
les trois ou quatre sur place et trois
jours pour revenir
il fallait que les engins et les hommes
tiennent pendant cette durée mais rien
n'était joué et cooper était resté 24
heures dans l'espace sur mercury mai et
7 et où c'était une mission très
importante
le programme apollo c'était d'abord une
fusée géante saturn 5 mais aussi un
module lunaire et un module de commande
qui devaient se donner rendez vous
autour de la lune si ce rendez vous
avait été impossible cela aurait changé
la suite du programme
le programme gemini avait été un succès
total la route vers la lune se
poursuivaient comme l'avait promis le
président kennedy
le projet apollo devait faire débarquer
un homme sur la lune avant la fin des
années 60
mais la question restait posée qui y
parviendrait le premier les américains
ou les soviétiques il était en avance
sur nous ça ne fait aucun doute
ils nous ont battu plusieurs fois pour
le premier vol sur orbite le premier
homme à marcher dans l'espace la
première femme dans l'espace ils sont
même allés sur la lune avant nous avec
un engin habité pendant plusieurs années
ils ont fait la course en tête nous
faisions ce que nous pouvions pour les
rattraper mais vers le milieu des années
60 ils se sont effondrés
ce n'est pas tant leur technologie qui
s'est effondré que leur direction
technique
ça a été un coup très dur pour eux les
petites rivalités existent entre nos
différents services n'étaient que des
problèmes mineurs à côté de ça ça à
paralyser leur développement
et ça leur a fait perdre la course avant
même le premier lancement d'apollo une
catastrophe allait frapper le programme
spatial américain le 27 janvier 1967
lors des derniers préparatifs de ce qui
devait être son premier vol en portant
des hommes
un incendie éclate à l'intérieur du
module de commande tuant les trois
astronautes gosse grissom et dwight et
rogers chez free
j'étais assise à cet endroit quand ils
sont morts et j'ai tout entendu
nous avons connu aussi bien de grandes
peines que de grandes joies dans cette
salle mais c'est ce qui fait toutes les
expériences qui va la maine sont les
émotions
il y eut pendant les années du programme
apollo des moments d'émotion à noël 1968
avec apollo 8 franck boorman jim lovell
et bill enders premier astronaute
américain à se placer en orbite autour
de la lune
lure le début de la genèse
m
apollo 8 fait un vol particulier nous
étions les premiers boorman anders et
ont droit à approcher de la surface de
la lune
tout d'abord tout ce que nous avons vu
était le noir du ciel puis nous avons
fait effectuer une rotation de 180
degrés à la capsule est là juste en
dessous de nous environ cent kilomètres
nous avons vu les cratères c'est la
chose la plus extraordinaire que j'ai
jamais ce fut aussi le moment le plus
saisissant de toute ma carrière
d'astronaute après la réussite des
missions apollo 7 8 et 9
le programme était prêt pour la
répétition générale du débarquement de
l'homme sur la lune les astronautes
d'apollo 10 tom stafford et jean sernam
descendirent avec leur module lunaire
surnommé snoopy à 15 km de la surface de
la lune sernam et moi sommes descendus à
13 15 km de la surface
yang est resté dans le module de
commande à une altitude de 100 km nous
avons passé la surface au radar nous
n'avons photographier et nous avons
repéré l'endroit où naît on se poserait
deux mois plus tard et puis nous avons
vu ces énormes rochers c'était
impressionnant et était plus grand que
le world trade center
avec la réussite d'apollo 10 la course
vers la lune entré dans sa phase finale
après on se pouvait maintenant décoller
emportant avec lui la promesse du plus
vieux rêves de science fiction qui
allait devenir une réalité
lorsqu'ils sont revenus nous avons
compris qu'à moins d'un événement
inattendu nous allions être les premiers
à réaliser la grande aventure de tous
les temps dans le domaine de
l'exploration et la technique
nos voyageurs survole la mère de la
fertilité
nous sommes le dimanche 20 juillet
cela fait exactement 100 heures 39
minutes et 50 secondes qu'ils sont
partis à sa poursuite il a fallu séparer
le thème de mad une excursion d'une aire
de la cabine principale
c'était le deuxième moment le plus
éthique il restait environ 30 minutes
avant le débarquement proprement dit
puis tout à coup le responsable du
guidage a dit nous avons un problème est
un des contrôleurs a répondu c'est comme
si on faisait une simulation et tout le
monde s'est détendu on l'a compris que
ça allait marcher car nous étions
toujours plus efficace quand il y avait
un problème ça nous stimule et c'était
notre raison d'être
nous étions là pour ça à 300 mètres
d'altitude
armstrong prend les commandes manuelles
il se met à la recherche du lieu prévu
pour débarquer
il disposait de deux minutes de
carburant pour se poser voyons d'alert
s'était allumée pour nous prévenir
qu'ils auraient déjà dû se poser mais il
était encore en l'air en train de
chercher et le contrôle nous annoncer de
façon très laconique qu'il ne restait
plus que 60 secondes
charlie duke nous a dit 60 secondes
il reste 60 secondes carburant il faut
qu'il trouve un endroit pour se poser où
nous serons obligés de les faire revenir
autant que nous puissions juger
il veut c'est entre 7 et 17 secondes de
carburant au moment où ils se sont
reposés l'atterrissage fut un grand
moment de bonheur
pas tellement pour lui l'instant en
lui-même parce qu'il signifie la
réussite de 300000 personnes qui avaient
travaillé pendant dix ans nous avions
réussi c'était le succès de 300
personnes nous avons arrêté le moteur
vérifier que tout était normal et 1 par
des instruments de puits neil et moi
nous nous sommes regardés
je lui ai donné un tape dans le dos à
cet instant vous nous sommes rendu
compte que nous avions fait ce dont
l'humanité rêver de plus et nous avions
la chance d'avoir été choisi pour mener
à bien cette merveilleuse entreprise où
habite ma peau
l'homme était dans la lune c'était un
moment historique le monde ne serait
plus jamais le même
pour moi apollo 11 était
l'accomplissement d'un rêve
j'ai toujours rêvé de voir l'homme aller
sur la lune c'est arrivé alors que je
tiens encore jeune et je crois que dans
l'avenir ça se révélera comme l'un des
tournants de l'histoire de l'humanité
quant à paul on s'est posés j'étais chez
moi à los angeles
là je suis sorti pour essayer
d'apercevoir quelqu'un sur la lune
évidemment c'était impossible mais
savoir que des hommes se trouvaient là
on va changer ma façon de concevoir la
recherche spatiale de concevoir ma vie
et celle des autres gens ce jour
fabuleux
il y à 25 ans j'étais arrivé à mon poste
de télévision
personne ne m'endors est éloigné madonna
n'existait pas même si elle est est
rentré je lui aurais dit pas tout de
suite je retenais mon souffle
je m'étais muni d'un micro et
magnétophones je ne savais pas ce que
j'allais dire quand ça se passerait et
je tenais à l'enregistrer depuis eagle
armstrong et aldrin contemple l'immense
cratère qu'ils ont failli rater lors de
la proche
tout est d'un gris d'argile autour d'eux
il fait noir dans le ciel après un repas
calme neil armstrong et buzz aldrin se
prépare à la sortie dans l'inconnu et à
la plus célèbre marche de l'histoire de
l'homme
quand neil armstrong est arrivé en bas
de l'échelle et qu'il a posé le pied sur
la lune
c'était comme si le temps s'était arrêté
je m'en souviens encore
il ya eu une cassure dans l'histoire de
l'homme c'était le début d'une histoire
nouvelle pour moi personnellement
c'était un moment de joie
c'était la première fois que l'homme
allait sur une autre planète que l'homme
faisait malheureusement notre projet le
projet synthétique s'était arrêtée en
mettant le pied sur la lune armstrong et
aldrin pénétrer dans un monde qu aucun
homme n'avait jamais explorée nous
sommes trouvés sur la lune l'expression
désolation magnifique est venue
naturellement
je n'y avais pas pensé avant je trouvais
qu'elle exprimer la beauté de ce que
nous avions et monsoreau cadre humain et
en même temps la désolation
au cours de leur visite
armstrong et aldrin ont ramassé des
cailloux fait des prélèvements sous la
surface et pris des photos
ils ont laissé leurs appareils sur place
ainsi qu'un drapeau américain et une
plaque commémorative
100 kilomètres plus haut à bord du
module de commande
michael collins passe toutes les deux
heures il pense à ses compagnons j'étais
content de me trouvait seul à bord du
module de commande
j'étais bien tranquille et tous les
appareils marché parfaitement mon
principal souci n'était pas le module de
commande mais le lem le module lunaire
s'il se passait quelque chose les deux
autres étaient bloqués sur la lune
c'est ça qui me préoccupait se poser sur
la lune était une première épreuve mais
pour remplir la promesse de kennedy il
fallait ramener les astronautes sur
terre c'était une autre tout le monde
était préoccupé par l'étape suivante qui
devait ramener les astronautes sur terre
il fallait d'abord les faire repartir de
la lune grâce au même fusée ils ont
retrouvé le chemin en sens inverse
jusqu'au point fixé pour le rendez vous
avec un taux longs
il est maintenant 12h55 à houston les
moteurs des gueules se remette en marche
les soupirs de soulagement sont telles
qu'on pourrait les entendre à 400 mille
kilomètres de là l'étape suivante était
le rendez-vous lui même les ingénieurs
de la nasa le considérer comme
l'inconnue la plus grande de toute la
mission qui me faisait le plus peur
c'était le rendez vous ce qui me
préoccupait c'était de récupérer cette
espèce de petit carcasse al'allure
bizarre
les deux véhicules se rapprochent l'un
de l'autre finalement les sécurités
s'engagent les harriman l'un à l'autre
il largue ne l'aiment et envoie le
signal convenu pour le retour
apollo on se dirige maintenant vers la
terre peu après midi il traverse la
ligne imaginaire qui sépare la zone
d'attraction lunaire et la zone
d'attraction terrestre le porte-avions
de récupération us hornet capte un
signal de tempête
les conditions météorologiques au point
d'impact en mer deviennent très mauvaise
apollo 11 file au dessus des îles
salomon la force d'attraction atteint
6,3 g et les parachutes se déploie de
450 m la capsule passe à 300 mètres puis
150 avant de plonger dans la mer ils
sont de retour ils ont réussi
l'impossible ce qui fut le plus
intéressant dans la récupération de la
capsule
ce fut les précautions incroyable que
nous avons dû prendre de peur d'une
éventuelle présence d'organismes
pathogènes en provenance de la lune dans
l'atmosphère c'était une de nos kraft
nous ne savions pas si nous n'étions pas
en train de rapporter quelque chose qui
peut être nocif pour la terre entière il
fallait mettre les astronautes en
quarantaine ce qui signifie que je
devais prendre toutes les mesures
possibles pour empêcher la dissémination
de tout organisme personnes
le savez de quel genre d'organismes et
il pouvait s'agir quelle mesure pouvait
comprendre
ne sachant pas de quel organisme il
fallait se prémunir c'était une tâche
assez délicate les astronautes sont
placés dans un endroit qui ressemble à
une caravane ils resteront en
quarantaine
ainsi que leur matériel pendant 21 jours
au cours desquels on effectuera des
tests médicaux et scientifiques
nous avons trouvé des effets nocifs du
matériel et ont été sur la lune ni sur
les animaux ni sur les plantes ni sur
les humains la seule chose que nous
avons constaté c'est une croissance plus
rapide de certaines plantes les laitues
poussé deux fois plus vite mais en
dehors de cela nous l'avons trouvé aucun
effet ensuite nous avons pris une douche
et nous nous sommes reposés sur le porte
avions
nous avons regardé des programmes de
télévision qui avaient été enregistrées
pendant d'autres vols songes les ai vus
j'ai tout de suite dit anel regarde nous
avons tous raté ce que je voulais dire
c'est que ce qui s'était passé de plus
important n'était pas là haut mais sur
terre je le dis maintenant avec un peu
plus de recul
ce qui est important c'est ce qui s'est
passé dans l'esprit des gens sur la
terre
la mission apollo 11 était terminée la
promesse faite au monde par le président
kennedy avait été tenu le flambeau elle
est maintenant passé entre d'autres
mains car ce n'était là que le début de
l'exploration du monde inconnu de
l'espace
où
on